Hey everybody, this is a super awesome episode. Actually, it's been a while since we did a language on the show, despite the fact that that is our tagline. We've covered a ton of languages. We definitely want to go back and do, for example, C++. That episode is something like 12 years old now.
大家好，这是一期超级棒的节目。事实上，距离我们在节目中讨论某种编程语言已经过去一段时间了，尽管这就是我们的标语。我们已经介绍过大量的语言。我们绝对想回顾一下，比如C++。那一期的节目现在大概已经有12年历史了。
But we've been on a really long journey talking about user experience, talking about, we talked about trees, tree data structures, a whole bunch of stuff. I'm really excited to come back to languages. And for that, we have Marcin Moskawa here, who literally wrote the book on Kotlin. He's the author of a variety of Kotlin books, including Effective Kotlin and Kotlin Coroutines, Android Development with Kotlin. And it's a real pleasure to have you on the show, Marcin. So thanks for coming. Thanks for having me here. Cool. So we definitely want to get into Kotlin and what are code routines all that but let's start with a bit of background you know what kind of what's your path and what kind of got you to the point where you are you know writing these books and you're you know really diving headfirst on a Kotlin you
但我们在讨论用户体验、树以及树数据结构等各种内容方面，经历了一段非常漫长的旅程。我真的很高兴能回到编程语言的话题上来。为此，我们请到了马尔辛·莫斯卡瓦（Marcin Moskawa），他可以说是写过Kotlin圣经级人物。他是多本Kotlin著作的作者，包括《Effective Kotlin》、《Kotlin协程》以及《Android Kotlin开发》。很高兴你能来到节目，马尔辛。谢谢你能来。谢谢邀请我来。太棒了。所以我们一定要深入探讨Kotlin以及协程之类的东西，但让我们先从一些背景开始，你知道的，你的经历是什么样的，是什么让你走到今天这个地步，去写这些书，并且每天都一头扎进Kotlin里？
know every day what kind of led you to that I mean my journey with Kotlin itself has started with frustrations from Java. I like to talk about it a few years ago because I've built a huge amount of frustration back then and Kotlin helped me release it. Now I barely remember that because I'm using Kotlin for over seven years, I believe. And I nearly forgot Java. I'm still using a variety of different languages for different purposes. But Java is one of the languages I'm trying to forget about. Okay, so what made you write all that Java in the first place? So did you go the college route? Or did you go straight into industry from from high school or how did that play out oh that's mixed a lot so i i was very into the college life i actually was doing two faculties so two different courses on university, having internships on both of them. But then I just had this life-changing moment
你知道的，是什么引领你走到这一步的？我的Kotlin之旅其实是从对Java的沮丧开始的。我喜欢谈论几年前的事，因为那时我积聚了大量的沮丧感，而Kotlin帮我释放了它。现在我几乎记不清了，因为我相信我使用Kotlin已经超过七年了。而我几乎已经忘了Java。我仍然在为不同的目的使用各种不同的语言。但Java是我正试图淡忘的语言之一。好吧，那么最初是什么让你写了那么多Java代码？所以你走的是大学路线？还是高中毕业后直接进入了工业界？或者说情况是怎样的？哦，这很复杂，我非常享受大学生活，实际上我当时在攻读两个专业，也就是大学里的两个不同课程，并且在这两个专业都有实习经历。但随后我迎来了一个改变人生的人生时刻。
when I decided to go to the Erasmus. That's the program where I can go to the other country, live there. I spent half a year in Rome and I decided that I just need to get independent and start earning my own money and live in my own way. So after coming back, I started working,
当时我决定去参加伊拉斯谟（Erasmus）交流项目。这是一个让我可以去其他国家居住的项目。我在罗马度过了半年，我决定我必须独立，开始赚自己的钱，并按自己的方式生活。所以回来后，我开始工作。
which was quite crazy, having two faculties and also a job. It wasn't full-time initially, but it was enough to survive. In the meantime, I was working as a developer. I finished those two degrees. And so my career mixed both of those paths. What were your degrees? Were your degrees technical or was it something else? One was computer science. Another one is closer to telecommunication. Ah, okay, cool. Nevertheless, the story with Kotlin
这挺疯狂的，既要兼顾两个专业还要工作。起初不是全职的，但足够维持生计了。与此同时，我一直在做开发工作。我完成了那两个学位。所以我的职业生涯融合了这两条道路。你的学位是什么？你的学位是技术类的还是别的什么？一个是计算机科学。另一个更偏向于电信。啊，原来如此，太棒了。不过，关于Kotlin的故事……
has started for me when I worked as an Android developer. And I was one of the early adapters of Kotlin. And back then, the community was, you know, I mean, community is still very positive, but it's absolutely incomparable what was then and what is now. You know, our community grew so much that no one, I mean, you cannot know all those people. There are literally millions of people using Kotlin. Back then, it was a very small hipster community
对我的开始来说，是我在做Android开发的时候。我是Kotlin的早期采用者之一。那时候，社区——我的意思是，现在的社区仍然非常积极，但那时和现在简直无法相比。你知道，我们的社区发展得太大了，以至于没有人——我的意思是，你不可能认识所有人。有数以百万计的人在使用Kotlin。那时，它是一个非常小的嬉皮士社区。
where we all were passionates and we were all supporting each other. And it was so, so fun. And I just wanted to give as much as I could. And I was writing about Kotlin and speaking about Kotlin and I was truly passionate about promoting it I still am in teaching Kotlin and teaching programming in general but you know that's that's not the same yeah I was I did a lot of hiking yesterday and so for some reason metaphor kind of comes to mind where if you're hiking this trail that's really common, maybe it's paved or something like that, then you can really hike it by yourself.
我们所有人都是充满热情的，并且都在互相支持。这真是太有趣了。我只是想尽我所能地奉献。我写关于Kotlin的文章，谈论Kotlin，我真的对推广它充满热情。我至今仍然热衷于教授Kotlin和编程，但你知道的，那已经不一样了。是的，我昨天进行了一场很长时间的徒步旅行，所以出于某种原因，我脑海里浮现出了一个隐喻：如果你走的是一条非常普通、可能已经铺好路的徒步小径，那么你完全可以自己一个人走。
But if you start going out in the wilderness, then you kind of need a way to reach somebody if something goes wrong. And so in the beginning, when you're riding Kotlin for Android, you're kind of out there. And so you need a lifeline, especially if you're doing it for work and it has to work, it's not just a hobby, then you need a community. You need somebody that you can go to who is Uber expert and you can say, look, I'm getting this really esoteric error,
但如果你开始走进荒野，那么如果出了什么问题，你需要一种联系别人的方式。所以在刚开始为Android编写Kotlin时，你就像是在荒野中。所以你需要一条生命线，特别是如果你是为了工作而这样做，而且它必须正常工作，而不仅仅是一个爱好，那么你需要一个社区。你需要一个你可以求助的超级专家，你可以说：“听着，我遇到了这个非常深奥的错误，请帮帮我。”
please help me. And now maybe the path is just so well traveled that you don't have to really socialize to get your app done. So it's just, you know, a blessing and a curse at the same time. Yes, that and that does change a lot. I remember when Google announced that Kotlin is becoming the back back then it was another language for Android. Right now it's the primary language for Android development. But I remember the day when they announced that it's becoming another language for Android development after Java.
而现在，这条路可能已经被踩得太平坦了，以至于你不需要真正的社交就能完成你的应用。所以这既是一个福气，也是一个诅咒。是的，这确实改变了很多。我还记得谷歌宣布Kotlin将成为——当时它是Android的另一种语言。现在它是Android开发的主要语言。但我记得他们宣布它在Java之后成为Android的另一个开发语言的那一天。
And I was like, okay, we are opening Champagne. It's a huge day for us and a friend of mine who was a bit older for a bit longer in this programming community
当时我想，好的，我们要开香槟了。对我们来说这是巨大的一天。而我的一位朋友，在编程社区里资历比我老一点、待得久一点。
he was really sad and he just looked at me and he said we just stopped being hipsters and everything changes now and uh i believe like a year later he left kotlin and he started another big thing so oh what is this big thing what is his next big thing he he he got um into eternum and all those smart contracts. Oh, okay, got it. I'm not sure if this truly became a big thing, but I've never truly researched that.
他真的很难过，他只是看着我说道：“我们不再是嬉皮士了，一切从现在开始都变了。”而且，我大约一年后听说他离开了Kotlin，开始搞另一件大事。哦？那是什么大事？他的下一个大项目是什么？他迷上了以太坊（Ethereum）和所有那些智能合约。哦，好吧，明白了。我不确定这是否真的变成了一件大事，但我从来没有真正去研究过。
But he was very fascinated when he started that. Wow, yeah, what an innovator. I mean, I don't know very much about smart contracts either, but it's almost a household name at this point. Yeah, I mean, there are many people like that um i i had a pleasure to work in quite a few startups and one thing that i truly enjoyed is the mindset of people that people just want to work on the break changing things and and change the world and do amazing amazing things and many of those people when startup finally becomes a serious
但当他开始做那个的时候，他非常着迷。哇，是的，真是一个创新者。我的意思是，我对智能合约也不是很了解，但它在这一点上几乎是个家喻户晓的名字了。是的，我的意思是，有很多这样的人。我有幸在不少初创公司工作过，我真正喜欢的一点是人们的心态，大家只想从事改变行业、改变世界以及做一些惊人事情的工作。而许多这样的人，当创业公司最终变成一家严肃的。
company many of those people can stay there and make a great money but they decide to leave it instead to to work on another big thing yeah that's right wow as. So, okay, so you were finishing up university and you're building Android, you're working on Android apps and writing a lot of Java and hating life. And you had a life-hating factory and then a factory implementation factory and you're just, oh my God, why do I have a million different factories and like every callback has to be a class. And so it's just driving everyone crazy, right? So, well, maybe you could talk about, you know, I threw out some stereotypes there, but what are the things specifically that really bothered you about Java? I think that the Kotlin in its most basic form is nothing really new. There are new things right now, like coroutines or multi-platform capabilities, and they are big, okay?
公司时，许多人其实可以留在那里赚大钱，但他们却决定离开，转而去从事另一件大事。是的，没错。哇，所以，你快完成大学学业了，你在构建Android，你在开发Android应用，写了大量的Java，并且痛恨这种生活。你有一个仇恨生活的工厂，然后又有一个工厂实现工厂，你当时想，天哪，为什么我有一百万个不同的工厂，而且每个回调都必须是一个类？这简直把所有人都逼疯了，对吧？所以，也许你可以谈谈——我刚才抛出了一些刻板印象——但具体是哪些事情真的让你对Java感到厌烦？我认为Kotlin最基础的形式并没有什么真正崭新的东西。现在有一些新东西，比如协程或多平台功能，它们很大，好吧？
But the base of Kotlin is just, I believe, how Java should look like. It is how I think Java would look like, more or less, if it were making hard decisions and evolving as it should evolve. You know, of course, the big problem of Java is backward compatibility. They do not change to not break people's code. So I'm not saying that Java made a poor decision. I'm just saying that if Java would make the changes it should make, in my
但Kotlin的基础，我认为只是Java本来应该有的样子。这就是我认为Java在做出艰难抉择并如实演进的情况下，多多少少应该有的样子。你知道，当然，Java最大的问题是向后兼容性。为了不破坏人们的代码，他们不会轻易改变。所以我并不是说Java做出了糟糕的决定，我只是说，如果Java做出了它本该做出的改变，依我之见。
opinion, it would end up looking something like Kotlin looks like right now. Plus it has some things that were designed well from the beginning. So Kotlin has a really well-organized typing typing system, something people do not see as important, but it's extremely, extremely important from the perspective of using our code. So when you say organized type system, are you talking about like the type hints and the type inference? So you could say, you know, val x equals three, and you don't have to go and find out, is it an int or a long or do you have a lot of that or what makes it organized? So for instance, in Kotlin, from the beginning, you have a type to represent nullable and not nullable types. Ah, right.
它最终呈现的样子就会很像现在的Kotlin。此外，它还具备一些从一开始就设计得很好的特性。所以Kotlin拥有一个组织得非常好的类型系统——这是人们往往认为不重要，但从使用代码的角度来看极其极其重要的一点。所以当你提到“有组织的类型系统”时，你是在说类型提示和类型推断吗？也就是说你可以写“val x equals three”，然后你不需要去搞清楚它究竟是int还是long，或者是你有很多这种特性，还是说是什么让它变得有条理？例如，在Kotlin中，从一开始你就有了一个用来表示可空（nullable）和不可空类型的类型。啊，对的。
What is extremely important, because only then you can have proper type safety mechanisms, something that is still not very well implemented by most modern languages. And what is more, Kotlin made a very strict relationship between those types. So a nullable type is a supertype of not nullable type. What opens a door for many important use cases. In Kotlin, everything is an expression. We also have a nothing type, an empty type, that is a subtype of all the type, but has no instances. It's another thing that seems minor from people who do not use that,
这一点极其重要，因为只有这样你才能拥有适当的类型安全机制，而这依然是大多数现代语言未能很好实现的特性。不仅如此，Kotlin还在这些类型之间建立了一种非常严格的关系。因此，可空类型是不可空类型的超类型（supertype）。这为许多重要的用例打开了大门。在Kotlin中，一切皆为表达式。我们还有一个“nothing”类型，即空类型（empty type），它是所有类型的子类型，但没有任何实例。这是另一件对不使用它的人来说显得微不足道的事情。
but it's really, really important on some use cases that allows language to to truly behave well and those are those are small things that are very hard to repair in the language once you publish that but that that were done really really well in in kotlin from the beginning cool yeah that makes sense what actually happens under the hood when you, is Kotlin a JVM language? So does Kotlin compile down to the JVM or is it something different entirely? In general, Kotlin is a compiled language. So it is compiled to something more simple. And in the version that is most often used, it is compiled into
但在某些用例中，它确实非常非常重要，它能让语言真正表现良好。这些都是小事情，一旦语言发布后就极难修复，但在Kotlin中，从一开始它们就被做得非常非常好。酷，是的，这讲得通。当你在底层实际操作时，Kotlin是一种JVM语言吗？所以Kotlin是编译到JVM，还是完全不同的东西？总的来说，Kotlin是一种编译型语言。所以它被编译成更简单的东西。而在最常使用的版本中，它被编译成JVM字节码，就像Java一样。然而，Kotlin有不同的变体，或者你可以称之为平台目标。有一种Kotlin.js，它被编译成JavaScript；还有Kotlin native，它被编译成原生代码。为什么这很重要？在Android上，这很重要，因为它允许我们制作既可以被Android使用，也可以被iOS使用的库。所以我们可以轻松地构建一个公共部分。团队们喜欢在这些公共部分中加入越来越多的内容。业务逻辑，你知道的，这对于两个平台来说通常都是一样的。
JVM bytecode, just like Java. However, there are different flavors of Kotlin, or you can say platform targets. There is a Kotlin.js that is compiled into JavaScript, and there is Kotlin native that is compiled into the native code. Why is it important? On Android, it is important because it allows us to make libraries that are used both by Android and by iOS. So we can easily make a common part. And teams like to include more and more on those common parts. Business logic, you know, this is generally the same for both platforms.
甚至是视图，现在有了一种新方法，即Jetpack Compose库，它允许你使用纯Kotlin通过Kotlin DSL以非常优美的风格创建视图，具备出色的自动补全功能以及绝对的类型安全。你知道，Jetpack Compose中的项目可以被编译为JVM并在Android或桌面上运行，但它们也可以被编译为JS并作为网站展示，或者被编译为原生代码。
Even views, there is this new approach, the Jetpack Compose library that allows you to create views in a pure Kotlin using a Kotlin DSL in a really nice style with a nice auto completion and with absolute type safety. And you know, projects in Jetpack Compose can be compiled to JVM and run on Android or on desktop, but they can be also compiled into JS and be displayed as a website or be compiled into a native code
并成为你想要的任何系统的原生应用程序。所以这是一个新功能，而且非常非常强大，它源于Kotlin是一个多平台语言这一事实。你可以使用Kotlin在任何这些平台上进行编写。
and be a native application for whatever system you want. So that's a new thing and very, very powerful that comes from the fact that Kotlin is a multi-platform language. You can use Kotlin to write on any of those platforms,
或者你可以用它来编写一个可以同时编译到多个平台的模块。iOS是如何工作的？所以你要编译成类似原生库的东西。你必须以某种方式创建某种Objective-C互操作（interop）或类似的东西，对吧？是的，完全正确。所以你可以说生成的结果代码是相同的。
or you can use it to write a module that can be compiled into multiple platforms at the same time. How does the iOS work? So you would compile to like a native library. You'd have to somehow create some kind of Objective-C interop or something, right? Yes, exactly. So you could say that the result code is the same
就像你编译Objective-C时所拥有的一样。是的，这里使用Objective-C来与Swift或Objective-C项目进行互操作。哦，有趣，非常酷。它会为你生成互操作层吗？还是你必须自己编写？它会自动生成。哦，哇，太酷了。它会为你生成互操作层吗？还是你必须自己编写？
that what you would have if you would compile an Objective-C. And yes, Objective-C is used here to interop with Swift or with Objective-C projects. Oh, interesting. Very cool. Does it generate the interop layer for you? Or do you have to write that yourself? It generates it. Oh, wow. Very cool. Does it generate the interop layer for you? Or how did you have to write that yourself?
它会自动生成。哦，哇，这太酷了。我正在使用一款名为Anki的程序中的抽认卡来学习知识，我想制作一些能够自动为这个Anki程序生成笔记的笔记。我用Kotlin为此编写了一个程序。我默认使用的是Kotlin JVM。但是为了将我的笔记转换为Anki，或者将Anki牌组转换为笔记，因为它是双向的，我每次都需要启动一个JVM程序，我不喜欢那样。然后我发现我正在使用Obsidian笔记——这是一个用来做笔记的程序，最近非常流行，你可以在其中用Markdown编写所有的笔记。我发现你可以为Obsidian制作一个插件。如果你为Obsidian编写一个插件，你可以添加一个按钮来基本上启动某个进程。于是我把这段Kotlin代码从Java迁移到了Kotlin.js，并用它来为Obsidian制作了一个插件。非常简单。几乎不需要花费什么力气。我想我唯一需要改变的是，我之前使用的是文件API，而我只需要摆脱它就行了。就是这样。其他所有东西的工作方式完全一样。我还在折腾它，但我已经让它跑通了。所以我现在拥有了一个Obsidian插件，里面有一个按钮，你知道的。
It generates it. Oh, wow. That's super cool. I'm learning things using a flashcards in a program called Anki. And I wanted to make a notes that are automatically generating a notes for this Anki program. And I wrote a program for that in Kotlin. I default in Kotlin JVM. But to transform my notes into Anki or Anki deck into notes because it goes in both directions I needed to start a JVM program every time I did not like that and then I figured out I'm using the Obsidian note for it's a program for for a notes for quite a popular one recently where you write all your notes in in markdown and i figure out that you can make a plugin for obsidian and if you write
“推送到Anki”或者“从Anki拉取”。它确实能用。我还在继续完善它，直到它完全稳定、直到我正式宣布并发布它之前，我都会这么做。但对于我自己的个人使用，它已经完全可用了，而且并没有花太多时间。是的，确实非常非常酷。所以，是的，实际上Obsidian看起来棒极了。我刚才去了 obsidian.md 看了看。我用的是 Workflowy。我对它不是很疯狂。我绝对要看看 Obsidian。这看起来太棒了。不过，作为一个只把做应用当成一种爱好的人。
a plugin for obsidian you can add a button that starts some process basically and i migrated this Kotlin code from Java into Kotlin.js and used it to make a plugin for Obsidian from that. It was very easy. Practically no effort needed. I think the only thing that I needed to change is that I was using the files API and I just needed to get rid of that. And that's it. Everything else worked exactly the same way. And I'm still playing with that, but I do have it working. So I now have a Obsidian plugin where I have button, you know,
所以我从来没有对为iOS和Android开发应用产生过强烈的渴望。我的意思是，开发同一款应用。所以我总是很好奇别人是怎么处理这一点的。这似乎是一个非常巧妙的方法，你用Kotlin编写代码，然后将业务逻辑放在一个共享库中，接着在你的主视图代码中与它进行交互。这真的很酷。所以你以前是用Java开发应用的。在某个时候，要么你不得不说服你的公司转向Kotlin，要么你不得不换工作。
push to Anki or pull from Anki. And it does work. I'm still working on that until it is stable until i announce that and publish it but for my own use it is already usable and and it did not take so much time yeah yeah that's really really cool so yeah actually obsidian looks awesome i just went to obsidian.md and took a look. I use Workflowy. I'm not crazy about it. I'm definitely going to check out Obsidian. This looks awesome. But yeah, as someone I've only made apps as a kind of a hobby. And so I've never had a strong desire to make an app for
当时发生了什么？结果是怎样的？我不得不换工作。我的意思是，当时波兰可能只有少数几家公司在使用Kotlin，我把简历寄给了可能其中所有的公司。你知道，Kotlin当时还在测试阶段，没有大公司愿意使用它。然而，初创公司确实在使用它。所以接纳我的公司是一家名为DocPlanner的公司。
iOS and Android. I mean, the same app. And so I always kind of wondered how people dealt with that. And this seems like a really clever way where you write in Kotlin and now you get your business logic in a shared library that then you interact with from your main view code. It's really cool. So you were working on apps in Java. And at some point, you either had to convince your company to switch to Kotlin or you had to change jobs.
不过你可能不知道它，因为它在美国没有业务。它存在于一些欧洲国家和南美洲的大部分地区。那是一个服务平台，作为一名医生，你可以在上面注册，人们可以给你评分。你可以拥有日历，它简直就像是医生和患者的助手，患者可以寻找最好的医生并查看他们的价格。是的，通过这种方式，很有意思。通过对这种早期技术的狂热，然后选择使用它的公司。
What happened there? And how did that play out? I needed to change jobs. I mean, back then, there were maybe a few companies in Poland using Kotlin and I sent resume to probably all of them. And you know, Kotlin was still in beta back then and no big company wanted to use it. However, startups did use that. So the company that accepted me was a doc planner. But I probably don't know about it
你实际上在某种程度上通过定义选择了那些处于前沿地位的公司。对于他们来说，承担风险意味着他们的领导层必须具备相当的技术水平。这有点像，这真的很有趣。我觉得这是一个挑选要加入的公司的良好信号，对吧？如果他们拥有和你一样对某种新兴技术的激情，那么我认为这是建立契合度（alignment）的一个绝佳途径。
because it's not present in the US. It's present in some Europe and a big part of South America. That's a service where as a doctor, you can register and people can rate you. You can have calendar and it's literally like an assistant for doctors and patients can, you know, find the best doctors and can check their prices. Yeah, that's interesting by, you. By being passionate about this early technology and then picking companies that are using it,
是的。我甚至听说，这是某些公司的一种策略，他们故意使用这些新的、未经测试的技术，以此来寻找那些有点疯狂的人——那些愿意拿更少薪水、做更多工作，只为了做他们充满激情和热爱的事情的人。这也是初创公司等企业的一个好策略，因为实际上找人变得更容易了——我的意思是，我听说过——在这些技术领域找人更容易，因为你知道，开发人员往往希望在技术方面走在其他人前面。而公司往往更不愿意使用那些尚未经过测试和验证能良好运行的技术。好吧。
you're kind of by definition picking companies that are sort of on the cutting edge. And for them to take a risk, it means that their leadership must be pretty technical. It's kind of like, it's really interesting. It's like, I feel like it's a good signal for picking companies to join, right? If they have this sort of same passion that you do about some emerging technology, then I think it's a really good way to build alignment.
所以帕特里克（Patrick）和我正在这里记笔记呢。如果哪天我们开公司了，我们会让每个人都用Piet语言或者那种全都是括号的语言来写代码。我开玩笑的。但这太棒了。我的意思是，另一件事是，这也是一种为你自己的未来投资的方式。所以如果你去了一家大公司，他们在使用PHP，就像其他人都在使用PHP一样，你学会了PHP，那很好。但如果你能加入一家公司——特别是如果你有水晶球，并且你知道这种语言将会变得非常庞大。
Yes. I even heard that it's a strategy of some companies that they intentionally use those new and untested technologies so they find people who are kind of crazy, who are willing to have less money and probably more work for doing what is their passion and what they love to do. Also it's a good strategy for companies like startups because it's actually easier to find people i mean i heard so it is easier to find people in those kind of technologies because you know developers pretty often want to be ahead of others in terms of technology. And companies are more often unwilling to use something that is not yet tested and proven to be working well. All right.
而且你在它早期的时候就加入了一家使用它的公司，你其实是在为未来的自己投资。是的，我一直把它看作是我们下注的选择。你知道，就像那些你可以顺势而为的浪潮。有些是陈旧且懒惰的浪潮，比如Java或Python，我真的很喜欢并尊重它们，但它们也。
So Patrick and I are taking notes here. If one of these days we ever start a company, we'll make everyone write in Piet or that language that's all brackets or something. I'm just kidding. But that's amazing. I mean, the other thing too is it's a way for you to invest in your future. So if you go to, let's say, maybe a bigger company and they're doing PHP, just like everyone else is doing PHP and you learn php that's great but if you can join a company that's especially if you believe like if you have a crystal ball and you know this language is going to be really big um and you join a company that's
不会给你带来太大的推动力，因为已经有大量的人精通这些语言、有经验、在教这些语言、有现成的资料等等。所以选择像这样的大型语言是一种非常安全的方式，但它本身并不能推动你的职业生涯。而选择一些新的、充满风险的东西，你知道的，一方面它风险很高，因为这项技术可能会消亡，字面意义上的消亡。但如果它发展得很远，它就能带着你一起腾飞。顺便说一句，我当时还坚信另一件事。
using it early on you're kind of investing in in your future self yes i always seen it as a as a bets we make you know they're like those waves that you can go with um there are those old and lazy waves like java or python that i really like and respect but it is also um not uh not pushing you much you, because there are already plenty of people who know those languages, who have experience, who are teaching it, who have materials, etc., etc. So it's a very safe way to choose a big language like this one, but it's not something that will by itself push your career. But choosing something that is new and risky is, you know, on one side, it's very risky because this technology might die, literally. But if it goes far, it can push you together with it. By the way, another thing that I truly believed back then,
我记得有一件事是Kotlin真的激励了我，让我非常着迷。但我真正热衷的第二件事是一个名为RoboVM的多平台库。它现在已经不存在了。那是一个非常棒的想法，你可以用Java或Kotlin编写受到支持的代码，并且这些代码。
I remember one thing was Kotlin that really inspired me, that I was really fascinated about. But the second thing I was truly passionate about was this multi-platform library called RoboVM. It does not exist anymore. It was a really nice idea that you can write code in Java or Kotlin that were supported and this code
不仅可以在Android上原生运行，还可以被编译成iOS上的原生代码，这样你也可以开发多平台应用程序。那么那个项目后来怎么了？我相信微软把它买下来并把这个项目杀死了。哦，是的，这种事经常发生。
worked natively on Android but it also was compiled into a native code on iOS and so you could also make multi-platform applications. So what happened to that? I believe that Microsoft just bought it and killed the project. Oh, yeah, that happens.
所以所有把时间和精力投资到这个迷人项目中的人，你知道的，都失去了一切。我的意思是，你知道，Java差一点也遭遇了这种情况。你知道，我的意思是，当甲骨文（Oracle)收购Sun时，曾有一段时间人们对使用Java以及编写自己的JVM版本的合法性感到不确定，诸如此类。而在那个时候，人们在。
And yeah, and so all the people who invested their time and energy into this fascinating project, you know, lost it. I mean, you know, that almost happened to Java. You know, I mean, when Oracle acquired Sun, there was a period of time where people were uncertain about the legality of using Java and writing your own version of the JVM and all of that. And at that time, people were
怀疑Java是否真的能在这场法律战中存活下来。我想它现在已经达到了“大到不能倒”或“大到不能垮”的阶段，或者随便你怎么称呼它。但我见过很多JVM语言，比如Scala、Kotlin。还有一个我完全想不起来名字了。它是基于Scheme构建的，但有很多这样的语言运行在JVM上，不过它们正在慢慢侵蚀Java的份额。我的猜测是Java保持稳定或者正在走下坡路，但我得去看看实际的数据才能确定。是的，所有的数据都表明了这一点。啊，原来如此。好吧，确实如此。
wondering if Java was really going to survive this legal battle. And I think it's just at that state where it's too big to fail or too big to fall or what have you. But I've seen a lot of JVM languages, Scala, Kotlin. There's another one that I'm totally drawing a blank on. It was based on Scheme, but there's a bunch of these that run on the JVM, but are slowly kind of eating away at Java. My guess is Java is stable or on the decline, but I'd have to look to actually see the data on that. Yeah, all the data indicate that. Ah, okay. Yep. There you go. So yeah, the the type safety and what i noticed when i um so i wrote a uh my own version of google photos so basically i have a s3 bucket and whenever i take
所以，是的，类型安全以及我注意到的一件事，当时我——所以我写了一个属于我自己的谷歌相册（Google Photos）版本。基本上我有一个S3存储桶，每当我拍下一张照片，我的手机就会等待Wi-Fi。当连上Wi-Fi时，它会检查该存储桶中还没有的所有照片，然后将它们上传。
a photo my phone waits for wi-fi when it gets wi-fi it looks at all the photos that it doesn't already have on that bucket and it uploads them. And so I have just a simple Google Photos clone type thing. And when I wrote it in Kotlin, there's a few things that really stood out to me. I mean, one was it was literally a decade since I made an Android app. So the whole ecosystem is way, way better now than it was 10 years ago. But it felt like I really enjoyed the editor, the integrated experience and all of the sort of quick fixes that were happening. And even the fact that I could, one thing that really shocked me was I could actually take Java code from Stack Overflow
所以我只是做了一个简单的谷歌相册克隆版之类的小东西。当我用Kotlin编写它时，有几件事真的让我印象深刻。我的意思是，首先，距离我制作Android应用已经过去整整十年了。所以整个生态系统现在比10年前要好得多、好得多。但我感觉我真的很喜欢编辑器、集成体验以及所有那些正在发生的快速修复（quick fixes）。甚至事实是，让我感到非常震惊的是，我居然可以把Stack Overflow上的Java代码。
or Java files from other projects, and I could convert them to Kotlin. And it could even in line convert blocks of Java code to Kotlin. That really struck me. It's just amazing how that, because it's not trivial to do that. I found that really pleasant, really surprising. Yes, that's from the beginning. Also, you can pretty easily migrate the whole project and that works. However, of course, it's far from being a good Kotlin code because it's a javish code. And the next step is to start using Kotlin idioms to improve readability and safety of this solution. But yes, a simple solution can be done by this auto transformation and it works really nice. Yeah, I mean, it's a great way to kind of get started.
或者来自其他项目的Java文件直接转换成Kotlin。它甚至可以内联地将整块Java代码转换为Kotlin。这真的惊艳到我了。这太神奇了，因为要做到这一点并不容易。我发现这真的令人愉快，也真的很吃惊。是的，从一开始就是这样。此外，你可以相当轻松地迁移整个项目，而且效果很好。然而，当然，它离写得很好的Kotlin代码还相去甚远，因为它是“Java风味”的代码（javish code）。下一步是开始使用Kotlin的惯用法（idioms）来提高这种解决方案的可读性和安全性。但确实，通过这种自动转换可以完成一个简单的解决方案，而且效果非常棒。是的，我的意思是，这是一种很好的入门方式。
And as you said, you can see what's going on there and then rewrite it or update it. Yeah, there is actually a cool tool that many beginners use. So if you have Android Studio or IntelliJ open, you can just go into tools, Kotlin, show Kotlin bytecode, and you can see what your Kotlin code is compiled to. So if you're a fan of JVM bytecode, you can read it there. If you are not, there is this button decompile, and this button decompiles your bytecode into Java.
正如你所说，你可以看到里面发生了什么，然后重写或更新它。是的，实际上有一个很酷的工具，很多初学者都在用。所以如果你打开了Android Studio或IntelliJ，你只需要进入“Tools” -> “Kotlin” -> “Show Kotlin Bytecode”，你就可以看到你的Kotlin代码被编译成了什么。所以如果你是JVM字节码的粉丝，你可以在那里阅读它。如果你不是，那里有一个“Decompile”（反编译）按钮，这个按钮可以将你的字节码反编译成Java。
It's a strange journey because we compiled Kotlin into JVM bytecode then they compiled it into Java and you can see how it works. That's a very useful tool for those who come from Java. They are learning Kotlin and they are trying to understand how something works. You can just see how this code would look like if it were written in Java, any code. Yeah, that is super, super cool. If I remember correctly, or maybe I'm wrong about this now, but at the time, Java doesn't have coroutines, right?
这是一段奇怪的旅程，因为我们把Kotlin编译成JVM字节码，然后他们把它反编译成Java，你就能看到它是如何运作的。对于那些从Java转过来的人来说，这是一个非常实用的工具。他们正在学习Kotlin并试图理解某些东西是如何工作的。你只需要看一看，如果这段代码是用Java编写的，它会是什么样子——任何代码都可以。是的，这真的超级超级酷。如果我没记错的话，或者我现在可能记错了，但在当时，Java是没有协程的，对吧？
So if you write coroutines in Kotlin, how does that end up? And you try to decompile it. Do you get an error or what actually happens there? Okay. So maybe I will start with what are coroutines? Yeah. Okay. Yeah, that's true. It's a good point. So people often say that coroutines are like lightweight threads. I think that's, I mean, it can be a good start as it might be a useful metaphor to understand that they are lightweight and they are kind of like threads. But it's also very confusing because coroutines are not threads. So coroutines are already present in many languages in some limited form.
所以在Kotlin中如果你编写协程，最终会变成什么样？当你试图反编译它时会发生什么？你会得到一个错误，还是实际会发生什么？好的。所以也许我先从“什么是协程”开始讲起。是的。好吧，确实如此。这是一个很好的切入点。人们经常说协程就像是轻量级线程。我认为——我的意思是，这可以作为一个很好的起点，作为一个理解它们很轻量且有点像线程的有用隐喻。但这也非常容易让人混淆，因为协程并不是线程。所以协程其实已经以某种有限的形式存在于许多语言中了。
Coroutines are present in JavaScript, in Python, in C Sharp. Any async await block is a coroutine. Any generator is a coroutine, but a very limited use of a coroutine. So now what a coroutine is. Coroutine is a piece of code, some kind of block that can be suspended at any point. You know, later you can resume it from that point. So the word suspended is very important because it's not blocked. It is suspended. So it means that when you suspend a coroutine, what you have is a continuation object. This is an object that has all the local state, literally something like call stack. So all the local variables of this function, of the function that called it, of the function that called it, etc. etc. So that's what continuation has. And this object is like a save. You can
协程存在于JavaScript、Python和C#中。任何 async/await 块都是一个协程。任何生成器（generator）都是一个协程，只不过是对协程的一种非常有限的使用。那么，什么是协程呢？协程是一段代码，某种可以在任何点被挂起的代码块。你知道的，稍后你可以从那个点恢复它。所以“挂起”（suspend）这个词非常重要，因为它没有被阻塞，它是被挂起了。所以这意味着当你挂起一个协程时，你拥有的是一个“延续体”（continuation）对象。这是一个拥有所有本地状态的对象，字面意思上有点像调用栈。所以这个函数的所有局部变量、调用它的函数的所有局部变量、调用那个函数的函数的所有局部变量等等，这就是延续体所拥有的东西。这个对象就像一个存档。你可以。
keep it in your local memory. Formally, you can even serialize it and later deserialize it. Nevertheless, at any point you can resume it and continue from where your function stopped. So it means that you can literally jump in the middle of the function and, you know, start from there. Perfect implementation of coroutines requires a control of platform to, you know capture this this stack and restore it kotlin does not have it because it does not control the platform so it simulates it by having those continuation objects that that that store it wait hang on let me let me dive into that because that that blows my mind so so how does kotlin able to store all the local variables?
把它保存在你的本地内存中。形式上，你甚至可以将其序列化，稍后再反序列化它。尽管如此，在任何时候你都可以恢复它，并从你的函数停止的地方继续。所以这意味着你可以字面意义上地跳入函数的中间，你知道的，从那里开始。协程的完美实现需要对平台的控制来捕获这个栈并恢复它，而Kotlin并没有这个能力，因为它不控制平台，所以它通过拥有存储这些状态的延续体对象来模拟这一点。等等，慢着，让我——让我深入探讨一下，因为这太让我震惊了——那么Kotlin是如何做到能够存储所有局部变量的呢？
Is that part of the Java JDK where you can get all of that? It's a simpler concept. So in Kotlin, the functions that can be suspended are suspending functions. They have suspend keyword. Such functions under the hood are passing this continuation object that is a reference to their local state. And this object is used to keep this local state when someone suspends it. The very important thing to notice is that this is not an additional cost. Because I mean, it is, but a very small one.
这是Java JDK的一部分吗？在那里你可以获取所有这些？这是一个更简单的概念。所以在Kotlin中，可以被挂起的函数被称为“挂起函数”（suspending functions）。它们带有 `suspend` 关键字。这样的函数在底层会传递这个延续体对象，它是对其本地状态的引用。而当某人挂起它时，这个对象就被用来保存这个本地状态。需要注意非常重要的一点是，这并不是一个额外的开销。我的意思是，它确实有一点，但非常小。
Because we are not copying this state. We are only adding another reference to it. So if you have a local variable with a list that is placed somewhere in the memory, you know, the variable is a reference to a point in the memory, then the continuation does not have a list. It have a reference to the same point in the memory. So creating those continuation objects is super cheap because, you know, you're not
因为我们并没有复制这个状态。我们只是为它添加了另一个引用。所以如果你有一个局部变量，里面有一个列表，它被放置在内存中的某个地方（你知道，这个变量是指向内存中某个点的引用），那么延续体并没有复制这个列表。它持有了指向内存中同一个点的引用。所以创建这些延续体对象超级便宜，因为你知道，你并没有。
copying the state. It's like a shallow copy. Yes. It's like a shallow copy, but we want it this way. Yes. We want it this way because, you way because if the continuation is suspended, then the local variables are gone because your execution is finished for this coroutine. But you still have a single reference to that in the continuation. And that's how it works. And that's pretty
复制状态。这就像是一个浅拷贝。是的。这就像是一个浅拷贝，而我们恰好希望如此。是的。我们希望这样，因为如果延续体被挂起了，那么局部变量就消失了，因为你的协程的执行已经结束了。但你在延续体中仍然保留了对它的单个引用。这就是它的运作方式，这相当。
smart. Of course, because Java has plans to introduce coroutines. And I believe that they will introduce them in a century or two from now on. And Kotlin is designed
聪明。当然，因为Java有引入协程的计划。而且我相信他们会在从现在开始的一两个世纪后引入它们。而Kotlin的设计。
to support that if they finally introduce that. Yeah, that makes sense. One place where I found myself needing to use coroutines, and this goes way back, I wanted to make an RPG game. And this was a long time ago. I was actually in high school, I i think and i only knew c++ and um you know if you've ever played any of these rpgs you go to the town and there's people walking around in the town and you can walk up to them and press the button on the joystick or a keyboard or
就是为了在他们最终引入时提供支持。是的，这讲得通。我发现自己需要使用协程的一个地方——这可以追溯到很久以前——我想做一个RPG游戏。这是很久以前的事了。我当时甚至还在高中，我想，而且我只懂C++，并且——你知道的，如果你玩过任何这些RPG游戏，你走到小镇里，镇上有NPC在走来走去，你可以走到他们跟前，按下操纵台或键盘上的按钮。
whatever and start a conversation right and they have some dialogue that they'll say on command when you're not talking to them they're kind of wandering aimlessly? And they have some dialogue that they'll say on command. When you're not talking to them, they're kind of wandering aimlessly or maybe they have a path that they follow or what have you. And so, you know, each person is kind of, you know, operating on their own timeline. Like you don't want every person in the town to move at exactly the same time.
或者诸如此类的事情，然后开始对话，对吧？他们会在你命令时说出一些台词。而当你没有和他们说话时，他们就在那里漫无目的地闲逛。或者也许他们有一条遵循的路径，诸如此类。所以，你知道的，每个人都有点像是在他们自己的时间线上运作。你可不想让镇上的每个人都在完全同一时刻移动。
It would look very robotic and weird, right? So you want to have each person sort of with their own timer that says, okay, you know, a few seconds have passed, let's move to the bookshelf and let's take some steps. Or, you know, I just took a step, now I have to wait a second. And so, you know, again, this is very early. So I thought, oh, I'll just have each person become their own thread. And when they're not not walking the thread will just be sleeping and what i found is yeah you actually can't create thousands and thousands and thousands of literal threads because there's so much overhead there and even a thread that's asleep you know
那看起来会非常像机器人一样诡异，对吧？所以你希望每个人都有自己的计时器，上面写着：“好吧，几秒钟过去了，让我们走到书架旁，迈出几步。”或者“我刚刚迈出了一步，现在我必须等上一秒钟。”所以，你知道的，这又是很早期的事了。所以我想，哦，我只要让每个人都变成他们自己的线程。当他们不走路时，线程就会处于睡眠状态。而我发现的是——是的，你实际上不能创建成千上万个字面意义上的线程，因为那里的开销太大了。甚至一个处于睡眠状态的线程，你知道的。
consumes a lot of resources and it turns out if you have a ton of threads that are asleep you end up running out of cores and it's just kind of a mess right so you end up having to uh do something else or you kind of like visit all of these characters and wake them up and say hey are you ready to do anything and they say oh no i need to sleep for another you know cycle i'll walk next cycle so you go to the next one so every cycle you kind of round robin go through all these villagers you know kind of waking them up letting them do a cycle and then going to the next one and it becomes really cumbersome because as you said if a villager has some internal state it needs to like wait uh you know 27 cycles before taking the next step you have to go and update that internal state and everything now has to be in uh like a you know c
也会消耗大量的资源。结果证明，如果你有大量的线程处于睡眠状态，你最终会耗尽CPU核心，这简直是一团糟，对吧？所以你最终不得不做别的事情，或者你不得不访问所有这些角色并将他们唤醒，说：“嘿，你准备好做任何事了吗？”然后他们说：“哦，不，我需要再睡一个周期，我会在下一个周期走路。”所以你再去下一个角色。所以每个周期你都以循环轮询（round robin）的方式遍历所有这些村民，你知道的，把他们唤醒，让他们跑一个周期，然后再去下一个。这变得非常繁琐，因为正如你所说，如果一个村民有一些内部状态，他需要等待，比如在采取下一步行动之前等待27个周期，你就必须去更新那个内部状态，现在一切都必须放在类似——你知道的，在C++中必须放在像字典（dictionary）或类似的东西里。所以你失去了类型安全性，这感觉非常不自然，对吧？好得多的是，如果你实际上可以拥有一个——不是字面意义上的进程，就像一个Unix进程那样，而是为每个村民拥有一个独立的例程（routine）。在这个例程中，你可以说：“睡上一秒钟，迈出一步，永远这样做”，而不用担心所有的开销。
plus plus has to be in like a dictionary or something and so you lose type safety and it feels very unnatural right what's much better is if you could actually have like a you know a not literally a process like a unix process but have like a you know separate routine for each uh uh you know villager and in that routine you could say you know sleep for a second and take a step and do this forever and not have to worry about all the overhead um and let let let the os handle you know keeping the state of all those people and everything and so so uh you know at the time i i didn't know about coroutines, so I had to implement a really ugly way. But I've always found coroutines really elegant,
并且让操作系统来处理维护所有这些人的状态等等。所以——你知道的，当时我并不知道协程，所以我不得不实现一种非常丑陋的方法。但我一直觉得协程是一种真正优雅、美丽的途径，用来处理许多、许多需要同时拥有各自内部状态的对象。当然。不过我可能无论如何都会用一个单一的计时器来同步它们。我没有做过大型游戏项目，但在小型项目中，我不会喜欢游戏的不同部分拥有独立的计时器，因为那样的话你的游戏就会超载你的电脑，某些事情会变慢，现在所有的元素都在按照它们自己的时间生活。我总觉得有一种趋势，倾向于用一个单一的时钟来同步一切。我宁愿使用对象。然而，Actor模型（actor model）似乎是这里会有所帮助的东西。而在Kotlin中，我们使用协程来实现Actor模型。
kind of beautiful way of handling many, many objects that all need to have their own internal state at the same time. Sure. But I will probably synchronize it with a single timer anyway. I haven't done a big game project, but in a small one I wouldn't like having independent timers for different parts of a game, because then your game is overloading your computer, some things are getting slow and now all the elements are, you know, living in their own time. I generally believe there is a tendency to rather synchronize everything with a single clock. And I would rather use objects. However, the actor model seems like something that could be helpful in here. And in Kotlin, we use coroutines for the actor model.
是的，你为什么不深入讲讲这个呢？因为这里有很多听众可能从来没有开发过应用。他们做Web或者做后端之类的。所以请把我们从应用开发连接到协程。它们是什么时候被使用的？对它们来说最好的用途是什么？
Yeah, why don't you dive into that? So like there's a lot of folks here who have maybe never built an app. They do web or they do backend or something like that. So kind of connect us from sort of the app development to coroutines. When are they used? What's the kind of best use for them and
是啊，你为什么不深入讲讲这个呢？这里有很多伙伴可能从来没开发过应用程序。他们做网页开发、后端开发或者类似的事情。所以，能否把应用开发和协程联系起来？它们什么时候会被使用？最佳的使用场景是什么，还有
why are they a good idea okay so there are a few typical use cases so the the most typical one is that let's say that you on your application you need to fetch some data from the internet and you need to wait for those data because it takes some time to get them from your API. The question is, how do you wait for that? So if you block your thread while waiting for the response, you need to well manage threads because there are some threads you should not block. Other threads you can block, but they are expensive and you should not block too many of them. So that's problematic. So coroutines solve that problem.
为什么它们是个好主意？好吧，这里有一些典型的用例，其中最典型的一种是，比方说在你的应用程序中，你需要从互联网获取一些数据，并且你需要等待这些数据，因为从你的 API 获取数据需要一些时间。问题是，你如何等待？因此，如果你在等待响应时阻塞了线程，你就需要很好地管理线程，因为有些线程是不应该被阻塞的。其他线程你可以阻塞，但它们的成本很高，你不应该阻塞太多。所以这就有问题了。因此协程就解决了这个问题。
You just suspend the coroutine when you wait for something and resume it when you got it. Then using coroutines, it's pretty easy to implement as in Kawaid. I mean, they are built into the Kotlin coroutines library. And there are two parts of Kotlin coroutines. There is a built-in support that gives you the capability to suspend, start coroutines, et cetera. And there is a library that gives you tools like async await or sequence generators, et
当你等待某些东西时，你只需挂起协程，并在得到结果时恢复它。然后使用协程，实现起来非常简单，就像在 Kawaid 中一样。我的意思是，它们是内置在 Kotlin 协程库中的。Kotlin 协程包含两个部分。一个是内置支持，为你提供挂起、启动协程等功能；另一个是一个库，它为你提供诸如 async await 或序列生成器等工具，等等
cetera, et cetera, with yield. And so then pretty often we use async await in a similar way as in other languages, but they are implemented using coroutines. Another thing is that if you are implementing a backend application, as Jason mentioned in here, if you start too many threads, it's a huge cost for your computer. So if you have a pool of threads that you use on your
诸如此类，使用 yield。因此，我们经常以类似于其他语言的方式使用 async await，但它们是用协程实现的。另一件事是，如果你正在实现一个后端应用程序，正如 Jason 这里提到的，如果你启动了太多的线程，对你的计算机来说将是巨大的成本。因此，如果你在后端系统中使用一个线程池，并且有非常非常多的请求，那么你需要在线程池中启动大量的线程，或者你需要让你的请求等待，这并不是最佳方案。每个线程至少占用一兆字节的数据。
backend system and you have lots but lots of requests, then you need to start a lot of threads on your pool or you need to make your requests wait, what is not optimal. Each thread is at least one megabyte of data.
每个线程分配一兆字节的数据。从处理器或操作系统同步的角度来看，这也是一笔巨大的开销。因此，如果你开始拥有，比方说一千个线程，它对你的处理器时间来说已经是一个明显的负担了，你知道的，仅用于管理它们的能量消耗。
Each thread allocates one megabyte of data. It is also a significant cost from the perspective of processor or operating system synchronization. So if you start having, let's say, thousand threads, it's already a visible burden on your processor time, you know, the energy used only to manage them.
而且这至少已经是 1 GB 的内存了。如果你有一万个，你的应用程序能正常运行的可能性非常非常小，而且你知道，在一个大型系统中，达到这种数量的请求其实并不难。是的，另一件事是，你可能会搬起石头砸自己的脚。我有几个故事，一个，嗯，帕特里克和我很久以前一起工作过。我们曾在一个项目上合作，当时我们在做一些图像处理。我们尝试了一种做图像处理的新方法。基本上，这全都是我们在桌面上做原型开发。
And it's already one gigabyte of RAM at least. If you have 10,000 of them, that's very's very very unlikely your application will will work fine and you know in a in a big systems you know the having those numbers of requests is not so hard to reach yeah the other thing is you can really shoot yourself in the foot i have a couple of stories one um patrick and I worked together a really long time ago. And we worked on a project where we were doing some image processing. And we were trying kind of a new way of doing image processing. And basically, this was all we were prototyping something on the desktop.
我很确定你可以纠正我的错误，帕特里克，但我很确定我们做的是，我们为每一帧创建一个新的线程或新的进程。再次说明，这是因为我们当时不知道自己在做什么。因此我们无法弄清楚为什么，你知道的，在大约 2 万到 3 万帧左右时，Python 程序就崩溃了。然后我们不得不在接下来的 3 万帧上再次运行它。这是因为我们真的不知道自己在做什么。我们没有意识到，好吧，这里有这么大的开销。我真正需要做的是使用线程池，或者更好的是，使用 async await，它在底层有一个线程池，并且会为你处理好这一切。还有一个类似的故事，实际上曾有一段时间，你知道的，街景（Street View），也就是谷歌地图中你可以下到街道级别查看街道照片的那项服务。
And I'm pretty sure you can correct me on this, Patrick, but I'm pretty sure what we did was we we created a new either a new thread or a new process for every frame. Again, this is us not knowing what we're doing. And so we couldn't figure out why, you know, right around around 20,000, 30,000 frames, the Python program died. And then we would have to run it again on the next 30,000 frames. And it's because we didn't really know what we were doing. We didn't realize, OK, there's this huge overhead. And what I really need to do is use a thread pool or even better, use async await, which has a thread pool under the hood and takes care of that for you. A similar story, there was actually a period of time where, you know, the street view, which is the Google Maps where you can go down to the street level and see the photos of the street.
该服务实际上存在线程泄漏。因此该服务的一些部分在创建线程后没有释放它们，也就是没有清理它们。所以曾有一段时间。现在，当我说是“一段时间”时，我指的是几年时间，街景服务（该服务的单个实例）只能存活几个小时，因为它最终会分配太多的线程并被虚拟机监控程序杀死。因此，解决方案也许不是几年，但绝对有大约半年的时间，解决方案就是保持足够的服务、足够的实例持续运行和启动。所以大约有半年的时间，街景服务就是这样勉强维持下来的。
That service actually leaked threads. So there was some part of that service that was creating threads and not releasing them, like not cleaning them up. And so there's a period of time. Now, when I say period of time, I'm talking years where the Street View service, a single instance of that service could only live for a few hours because it would eventually allocate too many threads and get killed by the hypervisor. And so the solution for maybe not years, but definitely for about half a year, the solution was to just keep enough services, enough instances up and running. And so for like half a year, Street View limped along with that.
而 AsyncAway 解决了所有这些问题。我的意思是，如果你对性能有要求，你仍然需要进行调优之类的操作。但是使用 AsyncAway 很难搬起石头砸自己的脚。是的。所以在 Kotlin 中，我们使用协程。我们使用协程。我们使用协程。我们发起一个请求。目前最典型的方法是在单独的协程中处理每个请求。这些协程拥有它们自己的线程池，
And AsyncAway solves all of that. I mean, you still have to do tuning and all of that if you're performance conscious. But it's much harder to shoot yourself in the foot with AsyncAway. Yeah. So in Kotlin, we use coroutines. We use coroutines. We use coroutines. We start a request. The typical approach right now is to handle each request in a separate coroutine. And those coroutines have their own pool of threads
因为 Kotlin 协程库对线程池有着默认的内置支持，所以当你启动一个协程时，你可以决定它应该在哪个线程池上运行。在这种情况下，它将在适合你机器的最佳线程数上运行。当然，这个数字就是你机器上的核心数。因此，如果你有一台 16 核的服务器，它将启动 16 个核心，并且可能有数万个请求会运行在成千上万个协程上。
because the Kotlin coroutines library has a default built-in support for pool of threads so that when you start a coroutine, you can decide on what pool of threads it is supposed to run. And in this case, it will run on the optimal number of threads for your machine. And that is, of course, the number of cores on your machine. So if you have a 16-core server, it will start 16 cores and probably tens of thousands of requests will be on tons of thousands of coroutines.
这实际上没有任何负担，它们交替运行在这 16 个线程上，仅在需要时运行。每当它们在等待诸如来自数据库或另一个服务的响应之类的东西时，协程就会被挂起。但是挂起和恢复是一个非常廉价的操作。所以它非常非常接近最优状态。也就是你知道的理论方式，即处理器只做它应该做的事情，也就是你的业务逻辑。是的，有一件事我一直很好奇，但我从来没有花时间去做实验来弄清楚这一点。你可能对此很了解。
That is practically no burden at all that are running on those 16 threads interchangeably, only when they are needed. Whenever they are waiting for something like response from database or from another service, the coroutine is suspended. But suspending and restreaming is a very cheap operation. So it's very, very close to the optimal. That is, you know, the theoretical way where, you know, processor only does what it should do. So business logic of yours. Yeah, one thing I always wondered, and I never took the time to do an experiment to find this out. You probably know this offhand.
假设你有 16 个核心，我创建了 17 个协程，并且它们都有很多工作要做。它是在这 17 个协程之间共享时间，还是先完成前 16 个然后做第 17 个？因此，协程只能在挂起点进行切换。所以如果这些协程从不挂起（这不太可能，因为我们通常使用协程来做需要挂起的事情）。所以如果它们从不挂起，你知道的，你刚才说了 16 和 17，那么其中的 16 个将一直工作到它们当中的第一个完成，然后第 17 个才能
Let's say you have 16 cores and I create 17 coroutines and they all have a lot of work to do. Does it share time between those 17 or does it finish the first 16 and then do the 17? So coroutines can only switch at the suspension points. So if those coroutines never suspend, what is very unlikely, because we generally use coroutines to do things that are suspending. So if they never suspend, you know, you said 16 and 17, so 16 of them will work until the first of them is done and then the 17th will be able to
启动。然而，即使在如此极其罕见的情况下，也有一些好的实践，比如使用带有无参数的 yield 函数，它仅仅是一个挂起点，仅仅是一个你可以进行切换并给其他协程处理时间的地方。我极其极其罕见地使用它，可能一生中只用过几次，因为它只在那些长时间阻塞线程而没有挂起的进程中有意义。所以要么做了大量工作，要么在进行一些等待。但在这种情况下，还有另一种情况，因为如果你有一个正在等待的协程，你使用的不是旨在高效的线程池，
start. However, even in such extremely rare situations, there are good practices like using there is this yield function with no arguments that is only a suspension point, only a place where you can have a switch and give other coroutines a time for processing. I use it extremely, extremely rarely, probably only a few times in my life, because it only makes sense in processes that are blocking threads without suspension for a very, very long time. So either doing a lot of work or doing some waiting. But in such a case, there is also a different case because if you have a coroutine that is waiting, you are not using the pool of threads that is designed to be efficient,
而是另一个名为 dispatchers IO 的不同线程池，它是专门为了被阻塞而设计的。所以正如我所说，针对不同的目的有不同的线程池。如果你有会阻塞的东西，有用于阻塞的 dispatchers IO。如果你有应该是 CPU 密集型的、正在进行处理的东西，有 dispatcher's default，它拥有的线程数与你 CPU 上的核心数一样多。而在 Android 上，最流行的是 dispatcher's main，这是一个只有一个线程的线程池，即主线程，它是 Android 上最重要的线程。所以顺便说一句，实际上这也是很有趣的，因为人们认为协程
but instead a different one that is called dispatchers IO that is designed to be blocked. So there are, as I said, there are different pool of threads for different purposes. If you have things that are blocking, there is a dispatchers IO to be blocked. If you have things that should be CPU intensive, that are doing processing, there is dispatcher's default that has as many threads as you have cores on your CPU. And on Android, the most popular is dispatcher's main, that is a pool of threads that only has one thread that is the main thread, that is the most important thread on Android. So by the way, actually, that's also funny because people think that coroutines
意味着多线程，它可以意味着这一点。但通常情况下，那是懒惰的开发，不过尽管如此，许多公司还是这么做了。通常情况下，Android 项目仅在单个线程上运行，也就是主线程。这完全没问题，因为它从不被阻塞，所以我的意思是，如果你做了太多工作，这就不是完全没问题，但如果你没有做任何 CPU 密集型的事情，只是一个瘦客户端，你知道的，获取数据并显示它们，这通常没问题，因为有了协程，你永远不会阻塞线程，你只在需要时、在你需要使用它之前使用它，对于没有 CPU 密集型操作的非常简单的应用程序来说，这是一种有效的方法，这很合理，所以——是的，完全合理。
means multiple threads and it can mean that. But pretty often, that's a lazy development, but nevertheless, many companies do that. Pretty often, Android projects run only on a single thread that is the main thread. And it's perfectly fine because it's never blocked so i mean it's not perfectly fine if you do too much work but if you if you are not doing any cpu intensive things only you know a thin client you know fetching data and displaying them it's generally fine because with coroutines you never block the threads you only only use it when you when you need it before you need to use it and that's a that's a valid approach for a very simple applications with no cpu intensive operations that makes sense so so yeah totally makes sense
我想，让我们以照片应用为例，你知道的，如果我使用 sqlite 进行扫描，我想它在 Android 上被称为 room，是对 sqlite 的封装，但如果我有某个 sqlite 查询，我将其与我的媒体进行对比，我在这里忘记了所有的专业术语，我的媒体服务，它说，好的，我有这 400 张图像要上传，所以我可以直接启动 400 个协程。它一次可能只会启动大约 8 个。如果我说 8 个核心，你知道的，应该或者 8 个线程应该，你知道的，为此分配，等待那 8 个完成然后做下一个。但我可以一口气启动全部 1 万个，因为开销太低了。然后，你知道的，最终它会处理完所有这些并完成。
i think let's use the photos app example you know if i i do a scan using the sqlite i think it's called room the wrapper around sqlite on android but but i have some sqlite query i compare it to my media and i'm forgetting all the jargon here my media service and it says okay i have these 400 images to upload and so i can start 400 coroutines right off the bat. It'll only start maybe eight of them at a time. If I say eight cores, you know, should be or eight threads should be, you know, allocated for this, wait for those eight to finish and do the next one. But I can start all 10,000 of them because the overhead is so low. And then, you know, and then eventually it'll chew through all of those and finish.
如果有些事情真的很消耗 CPU 怎么办？例如，出于某种原因，我想在手机上的照片中检测人脸。我实际上不这样做，但假设这是一个思想实验。所以听起来，如果我在这里说错了请纠正我，听起来你会做的是，你将创建一个线程池，嗯，可能不是所有的核心，因为你不想，你知道的，榨干某个人的手机，然后你将这 1 万个请求放入那个较小的线程池中，而不是主线程池或类似的东西，然后那些协程会，你知道的，垄断那个线程池直到它们全部完成，
What about if something is really CPU heavy? For example, I want to detect faces in the photo on the phone for some reason. I don't actually do this, but let's say as a thought experiment. So it sounds like, correct me if I'm wrong here, it sounds like what you would do is you would create a thread pool uh that's maybe not all the cores because you don't want to you know maximize someone's phone and then you would put these 10 000 requests into that smaller thread pool that's not the main pool or anything like that and then those those coroutines will you know monopolize that thread pool until they're all done,
但它不会让你的手机把口袋烧个洞或什么的。是的，有些工具可以做到这一点。你可以限制使用时的并行度。我的书《Kotlin 协程》中的整章“Dispatcher（调度器）”讲的就是这个。基本上，有两个典型的用例。其中之一正是你所描述的。因此，如果你有 CPU 密集型的事情，请使用 dispatchers default。它使用的线程数与你的核心数一样多。
but it won't make your phone burn a hole through your pocket or anything. Yes, there are tools for that. You can limit parallelism for your usage. The whole chapter, Dispatchers, in my book Kotlin Coroutines is about that. Basically, there are two typical use cases. One of them is exactly what you described. So if you have CPU intensive things, use dispatchers default. That uses as many threads as you have cores.
然而，如果你认为你可能会过度使用它，你可能会使其他进程饿死。这不好，对于这种情况，我们使用 dispatcher's default dot limited parallelism，我们设置一个限制，它可以是 1、2、4 或任何数字，现在你仍然在使用相同的线程，好吧，最终为了不让 CPU 密集型操作使用的 CPU 超过你处理器中的 CPU 数量，但你将你的具体使用限制在了一定数量的线程上，以免使其他线程饿死。
However, if you think you might use it too intensively, you might starve other processes. What is not good and for such a case we use dispatcher's default dot limited parallelism and we set up a limit and it can be one or two or four or whatever and now you are still using the same threads okay to in the end not use for CPU intensive operations more than you have CPU in your processor, but you limited your concrete kind of use to a certain number of threads to not starve others.
这是建议的做法。当然，这并不是唯一的办法。你可以非常轻松地通过新线程创建一个新的线程池。但如果你这样做，那么如果你将线程使用到最大程度，并且 dispatcher default 被其他人或某个其他进程使用到最大程度，你使用的 CPU 核心数就会超过你 CPU 中的核心数，这对于你的处理来说并不是最优的。我的意思是，如果线程数量只比最优数量多一点点，那并不是什么大问题，但它不如将你的 CPU 密集型操作限制在 CPU 核心数上那么优化。还有另一种情况。所以另一种情况是关于阻塞调用的。正如我告诉过你的，有一个不同的调度器用于阻塞调用。这个调度器也有一个限制。它之所以有限制，是因为完全不设任何限制是相当危险的，你知道吗？因为假设你正在使用某个库，它在从互联网获取某些东西时会阻塞你的线程。然后你启动了 1 万个进程并启动了 1 万个线程。如果你没有任何限制，就会发生这种情况，而且你的应用可能会崩溃或发生类似的事情。所以必须有一个限制。
That's the suggested way to do that. Of course, it's not the only one. You can pretty easily create a new pool of threads with a new thread. But if you do that, then if you use your threads to the maximum and dispatcher default is used by someone, but by some other process to the maximum, you are using more than number of cores in your CPU, what is suboptimal for your processing? I mean, it's not a big problem if there is only a few more threads than the optimal one, but it's less optimal than it could be if you would restrict your CPU
因此 Kotlin 团队一直在考虑限制。他们在野外冥想了多年。然后一束光从天而降，出现了数字 64。这就是默认限制。实际上，这对 Android 应用程序来说是一个很好的限制。如果你在 Android 上需要超过 64 个应用程序来进行阻塞操作，你可能做错了什么。然而，对于后端应用程序来说，这并不是一个很大的限制，因为有时在后端，我们只是需要更多地使用内存来加速某些进程。为此，
intensive operations to the number of cores on your CPU. There is also another case. So another case is with blocking calls. So as I told you, there is a different dispatcher for blocking calls. And this dispatcher also has a limit. It has a limit because it's pretty dangerous to not give any limit at all, you know? Because let's say that you are using some library that is blocking your thread when it fetches something from the internet. And then you start 10,000 processes and you start 10,000 threads. That's what would happen if you would have no limit and probably your app would crash or something like that. So there must be a limit.
我们也会使用 limited parallelism。我认为它应该有一个不同的名称，但它实际上是同一个函数，它没有添加新的限制，而是将这个调度器转换为一个具有不同独立限制的新调度器。因此你可以使用你自己的限制创建一个新的线程池。那么为什么我要谈论所有这些线程池，为什么不创建一个完全独立的
And so Kotlin team was thinking about the limits. They've been meditating in the wild for years. And then the light came from the sky and there was the number 64. And that's the default limit. And that's a good limit for Android applications, actually. If you need more than 64 applications for blocking operations on Android, you probably do something wrong. However, it's not such a big limit for backend applications because sometimes in backend we just need to use our memory more to speed up some processes. And for that,
线程池呢？关键在于我这里提到的这些池是一个大池的一部分，就像同一个湖泊一样。所以关键在于，创建一个新线程是有成本的，保留它也是有成本的。因此关键在于，你可能需要一个由 dispatcher's default 提供的线程，然后切换到一个使用 dispatchers.io 的协程。关键在于你没有改变线程。你可以停留在同一个线程上，但这个线程不再算作默认线程了。它现在算作一个 IO 线程。所以我们在复用资源。
we also use limited parallelism. I think it should have a different name for that, but it actually is the same function that instead of adding a new limitation, it transforms this battery into a new one with a different independent limit. And so you can create a new pool of threads with your own limit. So now why I'm saying about all those pool of threads, why not creating a totally independent
我们在复用相同的线程。限制创建线程成本的秘诀是什么？我们只是在复用相同的线程。多么完美的机制！因为我们仍然有之前设置的限制。
one? So the point is that those pools I mentioned in here, they are part of one big pool, like one lake. So the point is that creating a new thread is a cost and keeping it is also a cost. So the point is that you might need a thread by dispatcher's default and then switch to a coroutine that uses dispatchers.io. And the point is that you are not changing the thread. You can stay on the same thread, but this thread does not count as a default anymore. It counts as an IO right now. So we are reusing resources.
这个限制是无限的。所以你可以使用，IO 可以使用 64 个它们的默认值，我不知道，16 个。我们的自定义限制可以使用 100 个以及其他，这完全没问题。但如果没有必要，它们会复用相同的线程。它们只是，你知道的，在切换它们。这也使得以下成为可能，并且实际上它是这样工作的，那就是你经常在操作之间进行切换。所以你做一些 CPU 密集型的事情，然后你切换
We are reusing the same threads. What's a trick to limit the cost of creating threads? We are just reusing the same threads. What's a perfect mechanism? Because we still have limits that we set up before.
到另一个协程上，或者甚至将同一个协程切换到 dispatcher's io，因为你在做阻塞操作，然后切换到另一个，再切换到另一个，你可以在保持在同一个线程上的同时进行许多这样的切换。所以在不同的时刻，你使用的是来自不同池的限制，但你仍然停留在同一个线程上，所以你不需要真正的切换。它在许多层面的性能优化方面都做得非常好。是的，我发现一旦我弄明白了这一点，从开发者体验的角度来看，这是极其令人愉快的。
This dislike is infinite. So you can use, IO can use 64 of their default, I don't know, 16. And our custom limited can use 100 and other, and that's perfectly fine. But if there is no need, they are reusing the same threads. They are just, you know, switching them. And that also makes it possible, and it actually is how it works, that pretty often you switch with your operations. So you do something CPU intensive, then you switch
这需要一个学习曲线，但举个例子，你可能想在照片中检测人脸。然后一旦检测到人脸，你可能想要，比方说，在它们周围画一个矩形。所以，你知道的，这第二部分生活在，我猜是 main、rendering，或者某个不是这种需要很长时间的离板进程的线程上，你需要返回到用户界面进程，并画出这些框，或者至少告诉系统这些框已经准备好了。是的，这都是通过这个 with 关键字完成的，对吧？
into with another coroutine on the, or even the same coroutine into dispatcher's IO, because you do blocking, then into another one, into another one, and you can do many of those switches while still staying on the same thread. So you are on different moments, you are using limits from different pools, but you are still staying on the same thread, so you do not need to really switch. It's very well optimized in terms of performance on many levels. Yeah, I found that to be, you know, from a developer experience to be extremely pleasant once I figured it out.
我已经有一段时间没看这段代码了，但你基本上可以说，使用这个上下文，使用那个上下文，你能够在同一个协程中跳转上下文，做不同的事情，然后跳回来。是的，with context 函数允许你跳转到不同的上下文。它正式启动了一个新协程，但你甚至可能不会注意到这一点。是的，我发现任何可以避免消息传递的事情都是好的。消息传递似乎真的很有问题，因为现在你写代码时，
There was a bit of a learning curve, but just to give an example, you might want to detect faces in the photo. And then once you've detected faces, you might want to, say, draw a rectangle around them. And so, you know, that second part lives on either, I guess, main or rendering or some thread that isn't sort of this off board process that's going to take a long time, you need to go back to the user interface process, and draw those boxes, or at least tell the system that the boxes are ready. Yeah, it's all done with through this with keyword right it's
不再是在线程之间来回发送数据了。要把那个搞砸、让错误的线程去读取数据并使另一个线程饿死是非常容易的。我遇到了太多关于消息传递的问题，以至于这种方式消除了所有这些。你可以跳转到不同的上下文中并在不需要来回传递大量消息的情况下完成工作的这一事实。当你使用 with context 时，你正在挂起协程。
it's uh been a while since i saw this code but you kind of say like with this context with that context and you're able to in the same coroutine jump context do different things and then jump back yes with context function allows you to to jump into a different context. So it formally starts a new coroutine, but you might not even notice that. Yeah, I find like anything that avoids message passing is good. Message passing just seems to be really problematic because you now are not writing coding
所以从 with context 中，你可以返回一些将被用于前一个协程的延续（continuation）的东西。我的意思是，我认为如果你从宏观上看，将 Kotlin 拥有的东西与我们在 JavaScript 或 Python 上拥有的东西进行比较，async await 和序列构建器，我认为有几点。因为当然，最重要的一点是 Kotlin 实现了这一点，使得通过这种方法我们可以实现很多东西。这种支持非常、
where you're kind of sending data back and forth between threads. And it's just very easy to mess that up, to have sort of the wrong thread, read the data and starve another thread. And I've just had so many issues with message passing that this sort of like eliminates all of that. The fact that you can jump into different contexts and do work without having to sort of pass a lot of messages back and forth. And when you use a with context, you are suspending the coroutines.
非常强大且通用。这是一件好事。也许将来有人会采用它，做出一种新的、了不起的方法。但现在如果你比较 Kotlin 协程库，也就是我们实际使用的工具，JavaScript 和在实践中使用 Kotlin 协程之间的主要区别在于，首先，Kotlin 拥有强大得多的内置同步机制，因此如果你启动了一堆挂起函数，默认情况下你就是在等待它们，因为它们不会启动新的协程。
So from a with context, you can return something that will be used on the continuation of the previous coroutine. I mean, I think if you take a big picture and compare what Kotlin has, comparing to what we have on JavaScript or on Python, the async await and sequence builders, I think there are a few things. Because of course, the big point is that Kotlin implemented that so that with this approach, we can implement a lot of things. The support is very,
它们只是挂起函数。它们只是，你知道的，挂起函数。它们只是可以被挂起的函数。你总是可以使它们变成异步的（async），但你不需要这样做。你知道，在 JavaScript 中恰恰相反。一切都是异步的。你需要直接进行同步。并且同步机制存在于许多不同的级别上。这是 Kotlin 非常强大的一个地方。
very powerful and generic. That's a nice thing. Maybe someone will take it in the future, make a new, amazing approach. But now if you compare the Kotlin coroutines library, so the actual tools that we use, The main differences between JavaScript and using Kotlin coroutines in practice is that first of all, Kotlin has a much more powerful built-in synchronization so that if you start a bunch of suspending functions, by default, you are awaiting for them because they do not start a new coroutine.
另一件事是，我们拥有这些 dispatcher 机制，也就是管理线程。这是一个巨大、巨大的优势。我还没在其他语言中看到以这种方式实现的。另一件事是取消（cancellation），这是 Android 上非常重要的一件事情，因为在 Android 上，你经常会打开一个窗口、一个 Activity 或其他类型的窗口，然后立即关闭它。所以当你打开它时，一些进程启动了，而当你关闭它时，你应该取消它们。
They are just suspending functions. They are just, you know, suspending function. They are just functions that can be suspended. You can always make them async, but you do not need to. You know, in JavaScript, it's the opposite. Everything is async. You need to synchronize directly. And the synchronization mechanisms are present on many different levels. What is a very nice power of Kotlin.
因为如果你不这样做，那么一些处理就会发生，一些永远不会带来任何结果的处理，因为它没有要更新的视图，然后它会尝试更新那些视图，这会在后台导致一些异常，因为那些视图不存在，所以你需要取消，这是许多其他方法的一个问题，而 Kotlin 拥有内置的取消机制。这是如何工作的？所以——如果一个协程被取消了，协程内部会发生什么？它会抛出一个异常，一个运行时异常还是别的什么？
Another thing is that we have these dispatchers mechanisms, so managing threats. That's a huge, huge power. I haven't seen that on other languages implemented this way. Another thing is cancellation, a very important thing on Android, because pretty often on Android, you open a window, an activity, or some other kind of window, and you immediately close it. So when you open that, some processes start, and when you close it, you should cancel them.
有一章专门讲这个。好吧。编写起来并不容易。实现一个好的异常处理机制并不容易，你知道的，因为人们，如果你问人们如何做到这一点，他们的第一直觉就是直接停止进程，这是一个可怕的想法，因为通常你需要在事后进行清理。所以你的直觉其实真的很好，因为在挂起点会发生什么呢？
Because if you don't do that, then some processing happens, some processing that never will lead to nothing because it has no views to update then it will try to update those views what will lead to some exceptions in background because those views do not exist so you need to cancel and that's a that's a problem of many other approaches kotlin has a built-in cancellation mechanisms how does that work so so if a coroutine gets canceled, what happens inside the coroutine? It throws an exception, a runtime exception or something?
会抛出一种特殊类型的异常，即取消异常（cancellation exception），它会传播并关闭所有东西。这是一回事，这是停止当前进程的部分。同样在协程中，我们有这种父子关系，结构化并发，
There is a chapter about that. All right. It's not easy to write. It's not easy to implement a good exception handling mechanisms, you know, because people, if you ask people how to do that, their first intuition is to just stop the process, which is a terrible idea, because pretty often you need to clean up after yourself. And so your intuition is actually really good, because what does happen is out of a suspension point,
这是 Kotlin 协程的另一个非常强大的功能，我们拥有这种父子关系，结构化并发，Kotlin 协程的另一个非常强大的功能。因此，当你取消父协程时，它会取消它的子协程。所以它也会以这种方式传播。与此相伴，你首先可以，如果你有一个 finally 块，当你取消时它将始终被执行。所以这是有保证的。
there is a special kind of exception thrown, a cancellation exception that propagates and kind of closes everything. That's one thing, that's the part that stops a current process. Also in coroutines, we have this parent-child relationship, the structured concurrency,
其次，你可以轻松地在取消时设置一些回调。我们在许多不同的层面上设置它们。例如，执行网络调用的库，它们也会在你的或它们的挂起函数被取消时设置回调，因为它们可能还需要清理一些资源，以通知一些进程没有必要再等待等等，等等。是的，我的意思是，关于手机开发，我注意到的一件事是操作系统扮演了多么重要的角色，例如，让我感触最深的一个例子是，你知道的，我设置了这个，我不想让别人在计费的网络上，我
another very powerful thing of Kotlin coroutines, we have this parent-child relationship, the structured concurrency, another very powerful thing of Kotlin coroutines. And so when you cancel the parents, it cancels its children. So it also propagates this way. And together with this, you can, first of all, if you have a finally block, it will always be executed when you cancel. So it's guaranteed.
不想——我猜这里只有我一个用户，但我不想让自己在计费连接上，比如在 3G 或 4G 连接上，将这些大照片上传到 S3，对吧？所以我要求 Android 设置这个，我想它被称为服务（service），并且该服务仅在我连接 Wi-Fi 时运行。所以如果我断开 Wi-Fi，并且我有某个大的上传任务，也许我正在上传一个大视频，我需要它停止这样做，这样我就不会在月底收到一大笔账单。在实践中，其工作方式是通过取消正在执行该大型上传任务的协程。通过这种方式，操作系统某种程度上意识到了你的 Wi-Fi 状态，它会去取消你的协程。因此作为一名应用开发人员，我注意到我必须更加适应操作系统能做什么以及如何适当地处理它。
Second of all, you can easily set up some callbacks on cancellation. And we set them on many different layers. So for instance, the libraries that do network calls, they also set up callbacks on on yours on their suspending functions cancellation um because they they probably need to to also clean up some resources to to inform some processes that there is no need to wait for that etc etc yeah i mean one thing i i noticed about doing phone development is how the the os plays a much bigger role like for example the the one that comes out to me is um you know i'd set this up where i didn't want somebody on a metered oh i
是的，没错。我的意思是，我总是说你需要根据你选择做什么学科、做什么类型的开发来选择你的毒药。所以当然，在后端，你主要是在跟你的数据库作斗争，
didn't i guess i'm the only user here but i didn't want myself on a metered connection like on a 3g or 4g connection to be uploading these big photos to to the s3, right? So I asked Android to set up this, I think it's called a service, and the service only runs if I'm on Wi-Fi. And so if I get off of Wi-Fi, and I have some big upload, maybe I'm uploading a large video, I need it to stop doing that so I don't end up with some big bill, you know, at the end of the month. And in practice, the way this works is by canceling the coroutine that is doing that big upload. And so in this way, the OS is sort of aware of your Wi-Fi state, and it can go and cancel your coroutine. And so as an app developer, I noticed I had to be much more in tune with what the OS can do
它们正在改变结构，或者你需要对数据库进行操作以使它们更高效。还有你的 API，比如它长什么样？你支持哪些版本？当然还有分散且经常奇怪打包的业务逻辑。
and how to handle that appropriately. Yes, that's right. I mean, I was always saying that you need to choose your poison depending on what discipline do you, what kind of development do you choose to do. So of course, in backend, you are mainly fighting with your databases
在前端，你通常主要与不同的屏幕尺寸、CSS 以及组件的可复用性作斗争。而在 Android 上，我也看到你正在与之斗争的事情有两种。其中之一是与你的操作系统进行通信。另一个是设计你的视图。所以，你知道的，当然，为不同类型的屏幕尺寸设计视图有时会很耗时且令人讨厌。
that they are changing structure or that you need to make operations on databases to make them more efficient. And also with your API, so that how does it look like? What versions do you support? And of course, the spread it and often weirdly packed business logic.
第二件事是在许多层面上与操作系统进行通信。你如何处理通知，你如何处理网络，在一些不同的情况下会发生什么，你知道的，一个优秀的 Android 开发人员应该了解非常非常多的事情。我记得曾经有这样一个函数，你应当在其中清理你的资源。但事实是，在某些情况下，它没有被调用，它从来没有被调用过。因为如果你的应用被存盘了，如果它被移到了后台，然后内存被回收了，
On front end, you generally fight mostly with different screen sizes, with CSS and with reusability of your components. And on Android, I also see that there are two kinds of things you are fighting. One of them is communication with your operating system. Another one is designing your views. So, you know, of course, designing views for different kinds of screen sizes that can be, you know be time consuming and annoying sometimes.
那么它可能会在不调用生命周期的情况下被杀死。所以人们需要知道他们需要使用特殊的技巧来正确清理早期生命周期函数中的一些重要资源。所以在 Android 上，与操作系统斗争的内容非常非常多。是的，完全同意。我记得，许多年以前，Android 上的用户体验是多么生硬，你知道的，多么充满故障，它总是会冻结，因为人们只是在主线程上做事情。而且，我想在 iOS 上，关于 Objective-C，或者语言中的某些东西，如果你在主线程上做事情，iOS 根本不会编译。所以他们强迫你保持主线程的流畅。
And the second thing is communicating with operating system on many layers. How you handle notifications, how you handle network, what happens in some different situations, you know, is that there are many, many things that a good Android developer should know. I remember there was this function that where you should clean up your resources. But the truth was that in some cases, it wasn't called, it has never been called. Because if your application was stashed, if it was moved to background, and then the memory has stopped,
然后在某个时候，Android，我不知道他们现在是否强迫你，但在某个时候，Android 应用程序也变得流畅了。在某个时候，Android 创建者开始在你于主线程上进行网络操作时抛出异常。但这远非完美。人们在主线程上做了很多不应该做的事情。是的，绝对是这样。
then it could be killed without invoking the lifecycle. So that people needed to know that they needed to do special tricks to properly clean up some important resources on earlier lifecycle functions. So there are many, many things that are part of fighting with operating systems on Android. Yeah, totally. I remember, you know, years and years ago, the user experience on Android being so jagged, you know, so glitchy, where it would freeze all the time, because people were just doing things on the main thread. And, and I think on iOS, something about Objective C, or there's something in the language where if you did things on the main thread, iOS just wouldn't compile. And so they forced you to keep the main thread smooth.
但无论如何，这算是一个好的开始，至少应用程序现在响应快多了。是的，手机也更快了。嗯，那是真的，是的。我们有更多的资源可以浪费。是的，摩尔定律让所有界面都变得很酷，所以，这真的很迷人，人们怎么能——如果有人想学习 Kotlin，你有很多听众是高中生、大学生，他们可能在大学里学习他们的第一门语言，并且
And then at some point, Android, I don't know if they force you now, but at some point, Android apps became smooth as well. At some point, Android creators started throwing an exception when you made network operations on the main thread. But that's far from perfect. There are still many things that people do on the main thread that they should not. Yeah, definitely.
很可能不是 Kotlin。我的意思是，大多数大学都在教，我猜是 Python、Java 或 C++。所以如果有人刚开始进入这个领域，并且他们听到了我们正在谈论的内容，也许他们想制作一个 Android 应用或后端应用并且他们想使用 Kotlin，你推荐他们如何开始？这完全取决于你从什么水平开始。如果你从了解其他语言（如 Java 或 C#）开始，我认为有一个非常不错的 Coursera 课程，由 Andrzej Breslav 制作，
But yeah, it was a good start anyways, at least. It seems like apps are much more responsive now. Yeah, also phones are faster. Well, that's true, yeah. We have more resources to waste. Yeah, Moore's law rises all all interfaces cool so this is this is really fascinating how can people if someone wants to learn kotlin you have a lot of a ton of folks who listen in who are high school students college students they might be learning their first language in college and
他最初是 Kotlin 的主要创造者，后来是共同创造者，但担任设计团队负责人。还有 Svetlana Izakova，她真的是一位非常非常伟大的布道者和优秀的人，
likely not going to be Kotlin. I mean, most colleges are teaching, I guess, Python or Java or C++. So if someone's just getting started in the field and they hear what we're talking about, maybe they want to make an Android app or a backend app and they want to use Kotlin, what do you recommend is the way they get started? So it all depends on from what level do you start. So if you start from knowing other languages like Java or C Sharp, and I think there is a really nice Coursera course made by Andrzej Breslav,
在教授 Kotlin 方面极其极其胜任。我还推荐她合著的一本书，即《Kotlin in Action》（Kotlin 实战），它非常好地描述了 Kotlin 的所有特性以及它们的使用案例和一些关于使用它们的基本信息。如果你从零开始，Meta（Facebook）不久后应该会在 Coursera 上推出一门课程。我不能
initially the main creator of Kotlin, later co-creator, but head of design team. And also Svetlana Izakova, who is a really, really great evangelist and a great person
告诉你是谁编写了其中的内容，但我认为它会是一个非常好的课程。它是 Android 路径的一部分，但它的编写方式使得任何人都可以上手。
and extremely, extremely competent in teaching Kotlin. And I also would recommend a book she co-authored, and that is Kotlin in Action, that pretty well describes all the Kotlin features together with their use cases and some essential information about using them. If you start from the beginning, there should be soon a course on Coursera made by Mita, Facebook. I cannot
而且它，我相信是《Kotlin 基础》（Kotlin Essentials）。我相信是这样的。我也在写一本书，叫做《面向开发者的 Kotlin》（Kotlin for Developers）。它实际上是一个系列的书，因为我无法将我想解释的所有内容塞进一本书里。所以我把它拆成了三本书。它将是《Kotlin 开发者基础》。我目前正在编写《函数式 Kotlin》（Functional Kotlin），这是该系列的第二部分，我实际上已经完成了。它目前正在接受审阅，不同的校对人员正在应用他们的校对意见。它已经可以在 LeanPub 上购买了，但我认为它在亚马逊上架
tell you who wrote content for that, but I think it will be a really good one. It's part of Android path, but it's written so that it can be started by anyone.
不会早于今年 11 月或 12 月。我们在等待一个惊喜的嘉宾章节。我不想透露太多，但我们可能会有由非常优秀的共同合著这个嘉宾章节的人所撰写的迷人主题。还有《高级 Kotlin》（Advanced Kotlin），我计划在
And it's, I believe, Kotlin Essentials. I believe so. I also write a book that is Kotlin for Developers. It's actually a series of books because I couldn't match everything I wanted to explain on a single book. So I split it into three books. It will be Kotlin for developers essentials. I am working on at the moment the functional Kotlin, the second part of the series that I practically finished. It is reviewed at the moment and the different kinds of correctors are applying their corrections. It's already available on LeanPub, but I think it will be available on Amazon
明年年初开始写。我的书，如果现在是宣传我的书的时间的话。是的，说来听听。我的书不适合初学者。《Effective Kotlin》现在是写给 Kotlin 用户的。所以它是写给已经在使用 Kotlin 的人们的。它是成为更好的 Kotlin 开发人员的秘诀。我希望能够让人更多地理解 Kotlin，并且，你知道的，我在其中包含了许多好的实践和关于良好开发的大量想法。而且《Kotlin 协程》也不是写给
no sooner than maybe on November or December. We are waiting for a surprise host chapter. I don't want to tell too much about that, but we will probably have fascinating topics written by really nice people co-authoring this guest chapter. And there is advanced Kotlin that I'm planning to write
非 Kotlin 开发人员的。你需要至少了解一点 Kotlin 才能理解这本书。《Kotlin 协程深度解析》（Kotlin Coroutines Deep Dive）是我的一部心血之作，我针对 Kotlin 开发者撰写了它，从头开始教授 Kotlin 协程，直到我关于 Kotlin 协程所有想说的话。我为这部作品感到非常自豪。它基于我举办过的一次工作坊，
at the beginning of the next year. My books, if this is time for my books. Yeah, let's hear it. My books are not for beginners. The effective Kotlin is now for Kotlin users. So it's for people using Kotlin already. And it's a recipe for getting better in Kotlin. I hope for understanding Kotlin more and for, you know, I included there a lot of good practices and a lot of ideas for a good development. And also Kotlin coroutines is also not directed
哇，大概至少举办了 30 期。在每一期中它都在发生一点变化。所以我认为这是一本设计非常精良、深思熟虑的书。顺便说一句，第一系列书《面向开发者的 Kotlin》也是基于我从头教授 Kotlin 的工作坊。这也是一本经过深思熟虑的书。
to non-Kotlin developers. You need to know Kotlin at least a little bit to understand this book. But Kotlin coroutines deep dive is a position, a child of mine that I directed for Kotlin developers, teaching Kotlin coroutines from the beginning until everything I have to say on Kotlin coroutines. I'm very proud from this position. It's based on a workshop of mine that I conducted for,
太棒了。所以你有工作坊和书籍。这些书在 Kindle 或亚马逊上可以买到吗？或者你将书籍推送给人们的主要渠道是什么？我更倾向于人们使用 LeanPub，因为这是我生成这些书籍的平台。所以它们在那里是最新的。这也是一个我可以从销售中获得 80% 收入的平台。
wow, probably at least 30 iterations. With every iteration, it was changing a bit. And so I think it's a very well designed and very well thought through book. By the way, the first series of books, The Kotlin for Developers, is also based on a workshop of mine that teaches Kotlin from the beginning. And that's also pretty well thought through.
抱歉打断一下，是 LINPUB 还是 L-E-A-NPUB？Lean，就像，你知道的，像精益创业（lean startup）那个词。啊，好的，好的，LeanPUB。好的，是的，我们一定会把它放在节目shownotes里。而且，哦，是的，这里有大量令人惊叹的书籍。实际上，这是我第一次访问这个网站。非常非常酷。上面有很多了不起的作者。
Very cool. And so you have the workshops and the books. Are the books available on like Kindle or Amazon? Or what's your primary vector for getting the books out to people? So my preference is for people to use a LeanPub because it's a platform where I generate those books. So they are most up-to-date over there. And it's also a platform where I have 80% of income from sales.
我认为这是一个为开发者写书的非常棒的服务。你在修改后的 markdown 中编写代码，它会生成一个你拥有所有版权的非常棒的输出文件。所以你可以打印并分发它。你还可以获得这个可打印版本并在 KDP 上出售。或者你可以通过该平台出售，其中 80% 的收入归作者所有，这相当不错。而在亚马逊上，你知道的，来自电子书的钱非常有趣，真的非常非常少。
Sorry to interrupt, but is it LINPUB or is it L-E-A-NPUB? Lean, like, you know, like lean startup. Ah, okay, okay, LeanPUB. Okay, yeah, so we'll definitely put this in the show notes. And, oh, yeah, there's a ton of amazing books here. Actually, it's my first time on this site. It's very, very cool. There are many amazing authors there.
尽管如此，我看到那里的销量要大得多。所以对我来说重要的是，你知道的，这些书能够触及人们，人们能够阅读它们并从中学习。这总是让我很高兴。是的，我的意思是，这个 LeanPub，我刚刚输入了 PyTorch，这似乎是我最近花最多时间研究的东西。是的，它真的非常好。它直接告诉你作者将学到什么
And I think it's a really great service for writing books for developers. You write your code in a modified markdown, and it generates a really nice output file you have all rights for. So you can print it and distribute it. You can also get this printable version and sell it over there on the KDP. Or you can sell through the platform where 80% of income goes to the author, which is pretty nice. And on Amazon, you know, the money from e-books are funny, are really, really small.
我认为这是一个非常棒的为开发者写书的服务。你用修改版的 Markdown 编写代码，它会生成一个非常漂亮的输出文件，并且你拥有所有的版权。所以你可以打印并分发它。你还可以获取这个可打印的版本并在 KDP 上出售。或者你可以通过这个平台出售，80% 的收入归作者所有，这相当不错。而在亚马逊上，你知道的，电子书的收益很有趣，真的非常非常少。
Nevertheless, I see that the sales are much bigger there. So it's important for me that, you know, the books can reach people and that people can read them and learn from them. And that always makes me happy. Yeah, I mean, this LeanPub, I just typed in PyTorch, which is what I seem to be spending most of my time with lately. And yeah, it's extremely great. It tells you directly what the author will learn,
尽管如此，我发现那里的销量要大得多。所以对我来说重要的是，你知道的，这些书能够触及人们，人们能够阅读它们并从中学习。这总是让我很高兴。是的，我是说，这个 LeanPub，我刚刚输入了 PyTorch，这似乎是我最近花最多时间研究的东西。是的，它真的非常棒，它直接告诉你作者将学到什么，
what the overhead is. And it has a bunch of details on the book. You can see the contents. You can get all the previews. Yeah, this is super cool. I'm really glad you shared this with us. There is also a money back guarantee. So if you buy a book, you don't like it, you just, you know, ask, give me your money back. It automatically happens.
开销是多少。书里有很多详细信息。你可以看到目录。你可以获取所有的预览。是的，这太酷了。我真的很高兴你跟我们分享这个。这里还有退款保证。所以如果你买了一本书，不喜欢，你就可以，你知道的，要求退款。它会自动进行。
So, and I believe you have 45 days for that. Yeah, very cool. Yeah. As someone who, you know, my overall philosophy to folks is to just build something when they want to learn. And so following sort of eating my own dog food there, I did just jump into Kotlin by building this Photos app. And what I found was that, you know, now that we've talked, I realized that the way that I was setting up their coroutines, I was probably creating a lot of unnecessary thread pools.
所以，而且我相信你有45天的退款期限。是的，非常酷。是的。作为一个，你知道的，我给大家的总体哲学就是在他们想要学习的时候去构建一些东西。因此，为了践行我自己的主张，我确实通过构建这个相册应用直接上手了Kotlin。我发现，你知道的，在我们交谈之后，我意识到我设置协程的方式，可能创建了许多不必要的线程池。
I think they're called executors. This is this was like two years ago. So I'm drawing a bit of a blank. Yeah, we generally avoid that. Yeah, I mean, this is really fascinating. And so this is so, you know, I think, you know, get started by diving in, we just shared with you some resources that will put in the notes, almost every podcast listener app should have the notes. If not, you can go to programming
我想它们被称为执行器（executors）。这已经是大约两年前的事了。所以我有点记不清了。是的，我们通常会避免这样做。是的，我的意思是，这真的很迷人。所以，你知道的，我认为，你知道的，通过深入了解来开始，我们刚刚和你分享了一些会放在节目笔记中的资源，几乎每个播客听众应用都应该有节目笔记。如果没有，你可以去 programming
throwdown.com. And, you know, when you dive in, you're probably going to make all the same mistakes that all of the rest of us made when we wrote our first code. You can go back and read Kotlin coroutines, some of the more advanced texts, and make your app super responsive and fix other sort of developer landmines and all of that. I think it's a constant learning cycle. Yeah, I actually see it as a problem of coroutines. That's probably the biggest problem of Kotlin coroutines, that they are very easy to jump in and start doing something that somehow works. And it's perfect because coroutines are, I believe, extremely intuitive. So if you try to understand the general idea of how your program works,
throwdown.com。而且，你知道的，当你深入了解时，你可能会犯我们其他人写第一行代码时犯的所有相同的错误。你可以回去阅读 Kotlin 协程，一些更高级的文本，让你的应用超级响应并修复其他类似开发者的地雷以及所有这些。我认为这是一个不断学习的循环。是的，我实际上把这看作是协程的一个问题。这可能是 Kotlin 协程最大的问题，就是它们非常容易上手并开始做一些勉强能用的东西。这很完美，因为协程，我相信，极其直观。所以如果你试图理解你的程序如何工作的一般概念，
they do not disturb you. And when you see the code of coroutines, it seems quite intuitive. That's perfect. But from the other side, it's very easy to do something that makes no sense in coroutines. And you do not know about that. And people often do that. The one thing I pretty often see is people creating jobs. There is this job object. You know, people use it as a context.
它们不会打扰你。当你看到协程的代码时，它似乎相当直观。这很完美。但另一方面，在协程中做一些毫无意义的事情非常容易。而且你对此一无所知。人们经常这样做。我经常看到的一件事是人们创建作业（jobs）。这里有一个 job 对象。你知道，人们把它当作上下文来使用。
And this way they break their structured concurrency. So the cancellation does not work anymore and they have memory leaks. But they do not know about that because they are not tracking their memory. And there are many traps of this one. So it's very easy to use that without understanding that. And as a result, there are many people using that incorrectly, thinking that they are using it okay. And that's the biggest problem of coroutines.
通过这种方式，他们打破了结构化并发。因此取消操作不再起作用，并且他们会发生内存泄漏。但他们对此一无所知，因为他们没有追踪内存。这里面有很多陷阱。所以很容易在不理解它的情况下使用它。结果就是，很多人在错误地使用它，却认为自己用得没问题。这就是协程最大的问题。
I think that the point in here, I mean, there are languages that are forcing you to do things intentionally. Like by forcing that using a typing system or by the the structures that that that you need to use you need to use things intentionally and that forces people to to understand that to to not use it incorrectly that's that's good but of course one thing is that it makes um makes it very much harder to start with those solutions. Right, right. Is it good or is it bad? You can discuss on that.
我认为这里的关键在于，我的意思是，有些语言会强迫你有意地做事。比如通过使用类型系统来强制，或者通过你需要使用的结构，你需要有意地使用东西，这迫使人们去理解它，不错误地使用它，这很好，但当然，有一点是它让开始使用这些解决方案变得难得多。对，对。这是好事还是坏事？你可以讨论。
But the second thing is that it makes that extremely unreadable. And that's my biggest problem with Eric's Java. I can use it, I can understand it, but it takes me much, much more time. And if you take a student and make him or her read Eric's Java, it's very likely, sorry, that does not make any sense. If you make that person read code using coroutines, it probably might have some question marks, but it will generally be quite clear
但第二件事是，这使得它极难读懂。这也是我对 RxJava 最大的问题。我可以使用它，我也可以理解它，但这需要我多得多得多的时间。如果你让一个学生去读 RxJava，很有可能，抱歉，这毫无意义。如果你让那个人去读使用协程的代码，它可能会有一些问号，但它通常会相当清楚
of what's the meaning of the program. Yep, yep. Yeah, I mean, it's so true. I was thinking about when I started using Next.js, which is this JavaScript Node.js kind of front-end, back-end hybrid tool. Yeah, I found it very opinionated, and so I struggled a lot because
程序的含义是什么。是的，是的。是的，我的意思是，太真实了。我当时在想，当我开始使用 Next.js 时，这是一种 JavaScript Node.js 这种前端、后端混合工具。是的，我发现它非常有主见，所以我挣扎了很久，因为
it would say, oh, you can't do this. You can't do that. But then what I found was that when I was done, initially you want to say like, oh, how can I sort of hack this to get around this limitation? But then after you're going to Stack Overflow and other sites and finding out, oh, no, actually you can design the same thing you want in this other way and that's sort of what the intent is kind of puts you on the right course but you're right you are sort of fighting it the whole way until you reach your transcendence there and so and so the the having it extremely open-ended allows people to get started right away so it's it's a real double-edged sword. Um, but yeah, I found Kotlin to be very approachable. And, um, and so now I think if I did want to release my, my photos app, I would probably have to read your book and, uh, and
它会说，哦，你不能这样做。你不能那样做。但后来我发现，当我完成时，最初你会想说，哦，我怎么能用这种方法来绕过这个限制呢？但后来当你去 Stack Overflow 和其他网站发现，哦，不，实际上你可以用别的方式设计你想要的东西，这才是意图所在，它会把你引向正确的方向，但你是对的，你几乎一直在与它抗争，直到你在那里达到了某种超越，所以，所以这种极其开放的特性让人们可以马上开始，所以它真的是一把双刃剑。嗯，不过是的，我发现 Kotlin 非常平易近人。而且，嗯，所以现在我想如果我真的想发布我的相册应用，我可能得读你的书，然后
rewrite a bunch of it, but at least, you know, getting that first version kind of can give you that sort of dopamine, that adrenaline, you know, that you need to, to feel satisfied and then make the better version. Great. Thank you. Cool. Thank you so much, Marcin. This was amazing.
重写其中的大部分，但至少，你知道，得到那个第一个版本可以给你那种多巴胺，那种肾上腺素，你知道的，你需要它来感到满意，然后做出更好的版本。太棒了。谢谢。太酷了。非常感谢，马尔钦（Marcin）。这太棒了。
Really deep dive. I mean, I can, you know, we can tell that you are clearly an expert in this language in this area, and it's been a real honor having you on the show. Everyone should check out Marcin's books. We're going to post all the links in the notes. He also has workshops. You could go to kt.academy and see what sort of workshops are available there. And he's also available on Twitter, twitter.com slash Marcin Moskawa. So for the spelling, definitely check the show notes. I get this all the time where people put an H in my last name and all of that.
真正的深度探讨。我的意思是，我，你知道的，我们可以看出你显然是这个语言这个领域的专家，你能来节目做客真是我们的荣幸。每个人都应该去看看马尔钦的书。我们会在节目笔记中发布所有的链接。他还有工作坊。你可以去 kt.academy 看看那里有什么样的工作坊。他也在 Twitter 上，twitter.com 斜杠 Marcin Moskawa。所以关于拼写，一定要查看节目笔记。我经常遇到人们在我的姓氏里加 H 的情况，诸如此类。
So definitely check the show notes, click the link a lot. A lot easier than trying to spell either of our names. It was a real pleasure. And I look forward to kind of staying connected and seeing what the latest is with Colin. Sure, great. I will be happy to appear here again. Thank you for the invitation and hope to see you again. Cool. Thanks, everybody. And everyone, thank you for donating
所以一定要查看节目笔记，多点击链接。比试图拼写我们俩的名字要容易得多。这真的是一次真正的荣幸。我期待着保持联系，看看 Kotlin 的最新动态。当然，太好了。我很高兴能再次来到这里。谢谢你的邀请，希望再次见到你。太酷了。谢谢大家。谢谢大家在 Patreon 上捐赠
and supporting the show on Patreon. We really appreciate it. It is kind of crazy economic times. We take a whole hour for us to talk about that. But it is kind of crazy times. Every time I look at the news, it's a little wild. And so I know it's tough out there. I really appreciate everyone's support for the podcast. We put all of that money back into trying to get more kids and young adults on Programming Throwdown and learning about it. And thanks, everyone everyone for writing emails. We get so many emails from folks who, maybe they started listening 10 years ago
并支持这个节目。我们真的很感激。这是一个有点疯狂的经济时代。我们花了整整一个小时来谈论这个。但这是一个有点疯狂的时代。每次我看新闻，都有点疯狂。所以我知道外面很艰难。我真的非常感谢大家对播客的支持。我们将所有的资金重新投入到试图让更多的孩子和年轻人了解 Programming Throwdown 并进行学习中。谢谢大家写电子邮件。我们收到了来自许多人的大量电子邮件，他们可能在10年前就开始听了
and now they're in the industry. It's pretty spectacular. So keep sending those emails. It's a real treasure every time we, Patrick and I get one of those. So everybody, we will see you in a couple of weeks. Commons Attribution Share-A-Like 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在他们已经在行业里了。这真是太棒了。所以请继续发送这些电子邮件。每次我和帕特里克收到一封，都是真正的宝藏。所以大家，我们几周后见。知识共享署名相同方式共享 2.0 协议。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行演绎、改编，但你必须向我和帕特里克提供署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来发表评论。